thanks to the great courses plus for
sponsoring this episode
hey crazies you've been asking for a
good solid video in black holes for a
while and there's a reason I waited
until now to do it I had to cover some
relativity stuff first or this video
would have made any sense anyway here we
go
it seems pretty natural to start at the
beginning no no too far not the
beginning of the universe the beginning
of a black hole a black hole forms when
you get enough mass into a small enough
volume the best mechanism the universe
has for that is gravity say you've got a
star with a sufficiently large mass
anything greater than 20 times the mass
of our Sun ought to do it now not all of
that mass is going to form a black hole
only the stellar core will which is only
about three times the mass of our Sun
the other 17 solar masses are blasted
into space by a supernova at the end of
a large star's life the core is mostly
made of iron but it doesn't stay iron
for much longer
the cores own gravity collapses it into
a neutron star that's a ball of neutrons
about the size of a small city neutrons
are capable of exerting some outward
pressure thanks to quantum mechanics but
this thing is just too massive for it to
do any good the neutron star continues
to collapse under its own gravity
eventually the mass is compressed into
such a small volume that the space-time
around the neutron star is curved to an
extreme won't a perfectly black bubble
forms around it called an event horizon
this is a black hole
except it's not actually a hole this
graphic is not what a black hole looks
like ignore these a black hole is a
sphere it's a ball but it's so black you
can't tell it's 3-dimensional it just
looks like a circle from all directions
black holes have been a part of general
relativity since it was published in
1915 but the term black hole wasn't
coined until the mid 1960s black ball
isn't nearly as catchy exciting or scary
I mean tell me what you think that balls
in space
versus black holes is space look I'm not
saying black holes aren't scary because
they are they're terrifying but only
because they let you get closer than
usual
once those outer layers of the star get
blasted away the collapse of the core
has no effect on the gravity outside the
original cores volume if anything is
still orbiting it will keep orbiting
nothing is going to suddenly get sucked
in just because it's a black hole now
black holes don't suck all the weirdness
that happens around a black hole happens
inside the volume of the original core
as the core collapses it makes more
space accessible around itself you can
get a lot closer to that mass than you
could before now before we move forward
we're gonna make a big assumption for
simplicity we're going to assume this
black hole is not rotating yes I know
that's not very realistic but rotating
black holes really deserve their own
video making that assumption the first
thing you're going to notice is a sphere
of orbiting light which we naturally
call a photons here yeah you heard me
right light that thing that always takes
the straightest possible path through a
spacetime can orbit a black hole at this
place the diameter of this sphere is one
and a half times the diameter of the
event horizon that's about sixteen and a
half miles across for our three solar
mass black hole outside that sphere
stable orbits are possible inside orbits
are destined to collapse into the black
hole the next thing you'll notice is
that perfectly black and terrifying
event horizon let's talk a little more
about that the size of the event horizon
is called the Schwarzschild radius for
our three solar mass black hole it's
about five and a half miles
meaning it's about eleven miles across
which is a very small space to have
three solar masses crammed into and as
far as general relativity is concerned
this is the lower limit for the size of
a black hole the more mass you cram into
a black hole the bigger the event
horizon black holes grow as they eat why
do they call it a horizon excellent
question it's actually a very good name
a horizon is a
boundary we can't see beyond kind of
like the horizon when you stand on the
earth the curvature of the earth is
hiding those places from view likewise
an event horizon is a boundary hiding
events from view as in space-time events
yes the same kind of events we've been
talking about in these relativity videos
too the space-time diagram right before
the neutron star turns into a black hole
it's moving forward in time but these
axes don't belong to that neutron star
they belong to a distant observer like
maybe us on or near the earth to form a
black hole the neutron star must
collapse inside this boundary a boundary
that will eventually be the event
horizon but isn't yet speaking of which
what's that event horizon forms we call
that the outside edge of the black hole
instead of the matter still collapsing
behind it here's why as the last bit of
neutron star collapses inside the
boundary the event horizon comes into
being everything inside it is
immediately separated from the rest of
the universe
it's no longer part of the normal flow
of time once the event horizon forms
none of it now that happens inside it
will ever be part of our now a black
hole is what it looks like when events
have been completely severed from the
universe so in a way it's kind of like a
hole it's a it's a piece of the universe
that's missing so what's a black hole a
black hole is a spherical object with a
mass of at least three suns that mass is
so compressed and the space-time around
it's so curved that all events inside
its horizon are forever separated from
the universe a black hole is a missing
piece of space-time
so got any questions about black holes
please ask in the comments thanks for
liking and sharing this video don't
forget to subscribe if you'd like to
keep up with us and it's he'll next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
thanks to the great courses plus for
sponsoring this episode of the science
asylum the great courses plus is a
subscription video service where you can
learn about a wide range of topics like
science math history literature or even
how to cook play chess or become a
photographer you'll get unlimited access
to a huge library of over 10,000 video
lectures taught by Ivy League professors
and other experts around the world new
subjects lectures and professors are
added every month I've been watching a
series called mysteries of modern
physics time by physicist Sean Carroll
it's been helpful for some videos I'm
currently working on the great courses
plus is offering a free trial to science
Asylum viewers go to WWE courses plus
comm slash science asylum or click the
link in the description below to start
your free trial today oh one more thing
thanks to continued support from patrons
on patreon I'll be at VidCon next week
if any of you are there and see me don't
hesitate to come up and say hi if not
that's cool I'm hoping to post a vlog
about it in early July anyway thanks for
watching
[Music]